and round one of the ulti box Norway
chest blitz tournament it seems only
appropriate that the two pre-tournament
favourites would be facing off and as
you can see magnus carlsen and cara
nakamura are already going at it
Magnus employs a very soft opening which
is a personal favorite of mine and the
weird twisty noise in the background
makes me wonder if the audio was already
given as Sean Paul remix before I even
got a chance to look at this game after
a 6 III and Bishop f5 we have a pretty
standard approach by Nakamura to face
Tavares off the bishop here fully
intends to meet the LightSquared bishop
on d3 for a trade preventing white from
getting what would normally be be
potentially very good attacking chances
over here and after Bishop to d3 the
trade happens but Magnus gets something
in return for that which is that when he
captures with the C pawn the normal
dysfunction of having the night in front
of the pawn is gone though white now has
doubled pawns the main point is that
these double pawns are actually not the
most useless things on the board
controlling squares as we can see very
very useful for white as he develops
into the center Takara plays Bishop to
d6 and is offering a trade right back at
Magnus and he says no thank you I'd like
to keep my bishop and I will pin your
knight maybe getting some attacking
chances anyway despite the absence of my
light square bishop natural development
continues castles h6 quickly by Nakamura
the bishop retreats to maintain the pin
and kuroky Recker OV cub now one thing
to look at as Magnus lady 4 here is that
the tension between these two pawns is
going to be a critical aspect of the
ensuing middlegame Accardo plays Bishop
e7 since the immediate threat was
obvious to fork the bishop and the night
and this Bishop is also useful to unpin
than I don't have 6 but I'm coming back
to the tension here in the centre
talking about the tension between these
two pawns and then what it means for
these doubled pawns right behind them
the main thing is that when you have
tension like that in the center neither
side wants to break it obviously if
black captures on e4 white is never
unhappy with two dominant center pawns
now completely healthy and aron
nimzowitsch is clapping in his gray
but the issue is that okay obviously
white wants like to capture but blacks
not going to do it hit karo plays Knight
to b6 naturally he has the same
intentions to just build on this tension
because by the same right if white ever
captured here black would capture back
and now these double ponds have been
revealed for the absolutely horrific
weaknesses that they are so the tension
there that exists in the center but this
is one of the reasons we're going to see
all this Rima Newbury
Magnus plays the move okay to see one
hey Carter plays c6 and again the
tension has built the play has been set
and as any cheesy Hollywood director
would say and seen Magnus plays rook to
e1 again all the pieces are going to do
their best to maneuver and find useful
squares and not just for the current
position but assuming the tension will
eventually break you see rooks coming to
potentially open files if a trade
happened this work already did the same
if a trade happened but with both sides
positionally aware of what they don't
want to do a car not wanting to capture
and give Magnus a big center and magnets
not wanting to capture to weaken his or
at least reveal his weak double pawns we
continue to Cirie maneuvering moves
h3 is useful hey Carter wants to offer a
tray usually when you have less space
trades help Magnus almost touches the
piece on e7 as you can see there he
almost made that trade and stockfish
actually initially likes the trade but
then backs up and actually kind of likes
Magnus move having reviewed this game in
pretty deep detail for all of you to try
to offer whatever educational line
nuggets I can in a very fast blitz game
I can say that these two both played a
very very high level game with only a
couple critical moments where maybe one
side could have done something different
so hey Carmen plays rook to e8 that's
just a useful move again staring the
rook down saying I'm ready for the
tension to break just as you are it also
opens up this f8 square for either one
of these pieces
Magnus plays Adria Cara plays bishop of
fate as I said the square was open and
Magnus goal continues to be how can I
improve on my position how can I create
space without breaking the tension here
he finds a very high-level plan a lob
magnus carlsen style one that the
computer loves to Queen 82 playing more
like an engine than anybody else in his
generation of course is Magnus Carlsen
Queen a2 prepares the idea of b4 and
certainly if these squares come under
control and white is able to continue to
advance on this side of the board why
it's just going to gain space and have
freedom here comes before and Accardo is
is now in a tough position where it's
not to say he's clearly worse here but
it's obviously black is defending he's
kind of maneuvering kind of waiting for
white to figure out the plan plays
Knight h5 playing a little tickle with
the bishop and says I'll just back that
thing up and ask Magnus again I know
you're better here but how much better
what's your plan going to be you still
don't want to take obviously pushing
also leaves these pawns behind maybe
they're not as weak as they would be on
an open file but not ideal so Magnus
recognizes that again still putting the
rook on d1 still kind of preparing for
danger to happen Queen e7 is played you
could argue that maybe this position is
one of the few moments where her Karl
had something better to play with the
move a5 possibly getting that rook and
Bishop involved but I'm not really even
sure that's true he plays Queen e7 and
then the move Knight to d2 comes from
Magnus with pretty clear ideas he wants
to bring the knight to b3 will he pop
into a5 will he pop into c5 maybe it
just depends on his favorite color that
day is a blue or green and either way
Magnus and all seriousness is going to
be trying to continue to gain space on
the Queen side and build on the tension
hakarl quickly brings the rook to c8
Magnus continues his plan and Hikaru
retreats the knight once again trying to
keep his eye on the square and still
defending a slightly worse position
knowing that he doesn't want to break
the tension but asking Magnus exactly
what he wants to do plays Queen to d8
and here we go the fireworks will start
happening as soon as trades start being
offered it Carl quickly put the rook on
e7 which I think was the right idea not
to trade right away obviously if he had
traded by the way in the end of these
lines white is probably gobbling that
pawn so to stay with him in the live
position we do see the trade now madness
takes it with the D pawn I spent some
time looking into B takes with the
engine it's possible that the B file
could have been a an asset for white he
obviously decided against it and decides
to open up the position heading for this
plan with with d4 and Hikaru immediately
plays b6 knowing he doesn't just want to
sit on a lack of space this is a
position where I do think there was a
cool idea to talk about Magnus does not
play this move but a5 where the
sacrifice of the pawn and then a quick
grab
of the B file was an interesting idea
for white to consider especially because
that Bishop is so dominant it means that
black could never really have come back
and challenged the B file
Magnus didn't do it and I'm going to
stay with the live position because b5
was played we had a whole bunch of
trades that undermined the center and he
ends up winning the d5 pawn eventually
heading toward an endgame that we're
going to see where Magnus was still the
only one who could win sort of playing
for two results but I think he kind of
relied on the open tactical nature of
this position revealing something or
giving something more to white that he
got because it seems weird right now
Carlos rook is on g6 it's on a7 this
bishop is really nicely placed we got a
sexy knight on d5 and with that should
come a whole bunch of tactical
possibilities but in the end there
weren't there weren't the concrete
possibilities that delivered a serious
material advantage so I'm wondering if
those who want to back up the video and
look at that a5 suggestion by me maybe
that was another interesting thing for
Magnus to do to keep a sort of a
grinding edge more Magnus tile now after
Queen to be 7 he is still better so
don't get me wrong and hakarl has to
find critical moves rook a2 is a very
nice move trying to make sure his rooks
have the potential to meet for a date on
g2 if Magnus blunders Magnus plays
Bishop to c7 the engines do initially
suggest moves like Queen to g5 or Queen
a4 but neither really does anything the
bishop can back up and probably black
gets in trouble he plays Queen a8 which
allows the forcing combination you see
before you
Magnus goes for this pretty aggressively
because once you maneuver to the seventh
rank and that Knight has to move Bob's
your uncle he wins the pawn on c5 and
we're looking at a position where again
Magnus is clearly in the driver's seat
with this extra C pawn what's amazing
here is how hakarl really keeps his head
there's a lot of ways to try to defend
this drawn ending but he points the
absolute best move rook to c6 because if
he's going to trade into the rook ending
as Magnus does he actually is much
better served if his rook is already in
this position but in front of the C pawn
and so now as both sides sort of try to
run their pieces out white trying to
bring in his King black bringing up his
King aggressively to d6 it becomes clear
I think pretty quickly that Magnus is
going to lose that C pawn so the car
just has to make sure he doesn't lose
any pawns on the King side in the
meantime
the moves continue to maneuver around
Magnus realizes he doesn't want to
repeat and take a draw now so he'll
bring up the king and take the risk that
the King upon ending might be a drunk
hey Carl obviously has to play at first
to keep this King out of the King upon
ending but once h4s late Accardo
calculates as fast as anybody on the
planet and correctly decides he can risk
this kingdom upon ending his king we'll
get back in time and he is going to have
the chance to draw this ending very
dangerous and scary to go running in
like this when your King is so much
farther than the opponents but as we're
going to see he calculated it very
quickly and accurately as Occam Nakamura
does often this trade only means that
both sides are going to get their ladies
back on the board at the same time and
the players body language is already
revealing to us that both both of them
know this is simply a draw that Carl
finds the fastest way to get these
Queens off the board and we love these
two professionals playing it out to
their only Kings remaining before we end
this game and our live video coverage
courtesy of Peter Dockers who was
on-site in Norway and I want to come
back to the only other critical moment
where Magnus maybe had winning chances
was right here according to the analysis
I did with the engine probably in
hindsight once he realized he wasn't
getting the best winning chances in this
rook ending any any bishop move would
have been better Bishop to d6 maintains
better winning chances Bishop to e5
maintains better winning chances and
even Bishop to g3 all of these moves
remain remain in a position where black
does have to figure out how to guard
this Knight now with decent joint
chances black is black is not out of it
yet but I would bet that if he had it to
do over again Magnus would consider this
a much better fight for a win the
engines agree black lacks ideal
coordination to stay in from the pawn so
with that we bring our analysis of round
1 of the ulti box
Norway chess super blitz tournament
again faced off the two pre-tournament
favourites thanks for checking this out
please subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube and look for my next video
coming out this week where we where we
review the next not necessarily the next
round but the next game we had of Magnus
Carlsen playing at the Norway chess
super tournament